did you know the day of that you're
gonna lick the taser or did you
really just know in real time that it
was gonna happen um no jeff called me
and both the times with the scorpion and
the taser they asked if i would be down
and i said yeah
that would be down they actually asked
me if i initially would be down to do do
the snake poopies
and i said i would i was down
it was pretty rad how like being there
how well you handled licking a taser i
would have been a super [__] about that
you never looked and she did over and
over and over that's what people don't
always understand is that when we shoot
something you see it happen once but in
reality it happened over and over and
over yeah that's what jeff likes to do
well
how many times did you get stung by the
scorpion that we didn't see oh a lot
yeah and we used like three different
scorpions the one that we saw isn't even
the most painful one that one just like
hurts a little bit but there was this
one that was super tiny um i forget what
the smaller the scorpion the gnarlier it
was small it was translucent but it was
harder to see on film but that one was
so painful that's the one you actually
see me reacting to at the end where i'm
starting to sweat starting to sweat
um yeah that and that i just let them
because they wanted to see my lip puff
up like cartoon sure but it i did my
body didn't react that way i mean it
puffed up but not cartoon
i feel like you've been bitten by or
stung by a lot of scorpions yep a lot of
them like how many would you say
i mean the first time uh
was when i was on tour
in like
with the african emperor scorpions then
we actually went to africa and
restaurant with a bunch of scorpions is
that the small one
the african emperor one is the black one
okay that's the one that they shot yeah
that one's still not great but
yeah not as painful as the small ones
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
bestseller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude